blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpakman so of course we're still
very much dealing with the coronavirus
pandemic and in the midst of all of this
the United States now has a monkey pox
scare where 200 Americans are being
monitored and tracked for the rare
disease monkey pox more than 200 people
can you imagine what's going on more
than 200 people in 27 U.S states are
being tracked for possible rare monkey
pox infections they fear people may have
come into contact with the Texas man who
brought the disease in from Nigeria
earlier this month the man believed to
be the first monkey pox case in the U.S
since 2000 0003 was taken to a hospital
but is in a stable condition so far no
new cases have been found CDC is
concerned passengers who were on two
flights the man-made may have been
exposed he flew into Atlanta Georgia
from Lagos Nigeria on July 9th before
taking a flight to Dallas where he was
hospitalized
the chances of the disease spreading on
the plane were low because passengers
had to wear face masks important detail
that shouldn't be ignored if you don't
know much about monkey pox and I didn't
know that much about it until I
researched it today monkeypox was first
discovered in 1958 there were two
outbreaks of a pox-like disease so
pox-like chickenpox smallpox pox-like
happened in colonies of monkeys that
were being kept for research that's
where the name monkey pox came from the
first human case was recorded in 1970
and when we talk about contagious
disease we talk about the natural
Reservoir like where is Monkey pox right
now it's not known but African rodent
species are suspected of playing a role
in transmission as the BBC article
stated the first U.S case was in 2003
um there have been only 47 cases ever in
the U.S 200 people are now being
monitored and that initial introduction
in 2003 is believed to be because of a
shipment of animals from Ghana in humans
the symptoms of monkey pox are similar
to smallpox but not as serious they
start with fever headache muscle aches
and exhaustion the main difference
between smallpox and monkey pox is that
with monkey pox the lymph nodes tend to
swell the incubation period meaning the
time from when you are infected to when
you have symptoms is typically 7 to 14
days but like with all of these things
it's on a bell curve and it can actually
range from 5 to 21 days within one to
three days after the start of fever
there will often be a rash often
starting in the face and then spreading
elsewhere it tends to be a two to four
week illness in Africa and this is a
horrifying number
in Africa monkeypox has been shown to
cause death in as many as 10 percent of
those who are infected 10 percent
um and that just again brings us back to
so far the mortality The lethality of
kovid is under one percent
um and we say you know imagine if we had
a flu with an eight percent mortality
rate or a 10 okay the virus enters
through broken skin even if the skin
isn't visibly broken it can enter
through the respiratory tract mucous
membranes meaning mucous membrane
membranes meaning eyes nose and mouth
animal to human transmission can be a
bite or a scratch preparing meat contact
with bodily fluids and the most common
human to human transmission
is uh primarily through large
respiratory droplets there is no proven
safe treatment for monkey pox virus at
this time
um antivirus antivirals as well as
vaccinia immune globulin or Vig can be
used to try to deal with severity or
symptoms so this is like the absolute
last thing we need right now and of
course because the most common human to
human transmission method is large
droplet and right now because of the
covid pandemic passengers on flights are
required to wear masks the hope is that
none of the 200 passengers that have
been identified as exposed will actually
end up being infected but not exactly
the news that we were hoping for that's
for sure let's talk next about a new
poll from CBS news that really
highlights
the degree to which we're in serious
trouble in this country because of the
things that people believe
disproportionately right-wingers
disproportionately Republicans
disproportionately trumpists now some
will write in and say you know David uh
uh you are over exaggerating the degree
to which these problems are among the
American right and I would say no I'm
not the data actually tells us that
that's exactly the case so let's take a
look at
um at the poll CBS News uh still more to
learn about January 6th most Americans
say some of the data here is concerning
and some is not we'll look at some of
the questions when it comes to the
January 6th attack on the capital
72 percent of Americans say there is
more to learn and 28 percent say we know
all there is to know this is one of
those questions where in principle
there's nothing concerning here it was a
complex event in the sense that it
involved a lot of moving Parts it was
multifaceted in that it was Donald Trump
and Republicans and right when media and
others fomending the idea that the
election was stolen and I would agree
there is still more to learn the problem
is a lot of the people who say there's
still more to learn what they mean by
that is even at the top level that this
was violent right-wingers inspired by
Republicans with the lie that the
election was stolen which it wasn't
that's not even something that they
would accept so this is actually quite
concerning
um among Republicans when they were
asked about the actions of those who
forced their way into the capital the
number of Republicans that strongly
disapprove of the riots has declined by
12 points in other words more people uh
now at least to some degree approve of
what took place on January 6th and most
of that is in somewhat a proof there's
an increase in people that disapprove
but only somewhat
and so the point here is the strong
Republican opposition condemnation of
what happened on January 6th has
declined 12 points since January
what uh how would you describe what
happened at the Capitol
um
55 of trump voters describe what
happened at the Capitol as a defense of
freedom
and 51 of trumpists describe what
happened at the Capitol as patriotism
this is absolutely unconscionable now if
you're looking at the graphic 20 of
trump voters call what happened on the
sixth an insurrection
I'm actually surprised that even 20 of
them are willing to call it that this is
the type of now I'm not saying these
people are Nazis that's not what I'm
saying what I am saying though is that
this level of cognitive dissonance with
what took place on that day
is the type of thing that created a
vacuum in which Hitler was able to seize
power in 1930s Germany I'm not saying
anyone is Hitler I'm not saying anyone
is a Nazi but this is the type of thing
where when you see people this
disconnected 55 percent of trump voters
say those riots that violent
insurrections coup attempt that was a
defense of Freedom that's really really
dangerous stuff and in particular it was
a riot fomented uh by the then sitting
president
um 66 of all respondents say that U.S
democracy today is threatened and 34 say
it is secure this is a really
complicated
um question and unfortunately it's like
I don't even know that these polls give
us what we need to know because there
are people on the left who believe
democracy is threatened because Trump
and Republicans tried to overturn the
overturn the results of the election
there are people on the right who think
that democracy is threatened because
they believe that Joe Biden didn't
really win and is somehow now the
president so even a simple question like
democracy is threatened today the answer
doesn't really tell us much because the
reasons why people say yes very
dramatically the bottom line is this was
an attempt to overturn the election
results based on the LIE that it was
stolen
that riotous Insurrection was fomented
by the then sitting president
it was uh uh it was bad enough how the
right reacted at the time but six months
later they are sort of you could call it
a revisionist history you could call it
a group delusion
whatever you call it the percentage of
Republicans who don't think it was that
serious has gone up in the five months
since of six months since it took place
and the percentage of Republicans and
Trump voters who say it was a positive
act to defend Freedom has gone up
dramatically so what is the takeaway
the takeaway continues to be number one
I don't know how we fixed this I I just
have I'm out of ideas guys
number two the extremist faction of the
Republican party is the dominant Wing if
you are
a vile Republican in most ways like Liz
Cheney is but you think guys this
election stuff makes us look stupid you
are now apparently in the minority in
the Republican party at least as far as
they're willing to admit publicly and
then final takeaway
Joe manchin and Kirsten Cinema two
Democratic senators who insist that we
want to find common ground with
Republicans we want to work together we
need to find compromise that is between
what Democrats and Republicans want
these are the people that you were
trying to do that with the people 55
percent who say the riots were a defense
of freedom
only 20 percent of whom are willing to
say it was an attempted Insurrection Joe
manchin and Kirsten Cinema how exactly
do you find common ground with those
people it's a genuine question we're
really really in trouble
I want to remind you the David Pacman
show is not in trouble we are actually
on the precipice of our 16th anniversary
at the completion of Monday August 16th
it will be our 16th anniversary and so
on the 16th 16th for 16 it's very 16
related we're going to do a membership
special if you've been thinking of
signing up we're primarily funded by our
viewers and listeners like you through
the membership program Monday August
16th we'll be doing a big one day
membership special I hope that you will
get on my newsletter at davidpackman.com
and then Monday the 16th you'll get a
fantastic email telling you how to take
advantage of this criminally low
membership discount
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction category stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the David packman show
does depend on the support of great
people like you and even the people who
are the haters but they still value the
show and sign up at joinpakman.com our
membership program gives you great
access wide and long access to all sorts
of great member benefits you can sign up
at joinpakman.com let's get to some
callers and see what is on the minds of
the great people in our audience we do
this now via Discord you can find and
join the Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord why don't we start today with
Harper from South Carolina Harper you
were on the air
hey David
uh so I was just wondering I saw your
episode on Tuesday about
how you know
Fox is kind of changing their tone a
little bit and then I saw today I saw
actually Sean Hannity I don't know when
it was basically just urging the people
watching to get the vaccine do the
research and that sort of thing
do you think that's actually going to be
effective because I feel like that's
probably one of the most effective
things that could could be done I do now
I I want to make one caveat here add one
caveat which is even as we've seen Fox
over the last 72 hours become much more
pro-vaccine there's still a bunch of
anti-vaccine stuff happening on the
channel but you're completely right and
we've covered that there seems to be
overall a different tone I think it will
make it a a big impact when people
um people uh take advice from people
they trust and as sad as it is there's
millions of people in this country that
trust Fox News and nobody else and so I
hope it makes a difference I just want
people to get vaccinated why this is
happening I don't know one one thought
was that there's like a lawsuit concern
that's motivating this another one is it
was claimed that there have been
discussions between the Biden White
House and Fox News and that that
whatever was discussed is the
explanation for the change from Fox News
all the Fox News has denied that
um you know the cynical me says did did
the White House make some promises to
Fox about Biden interviews or events if
they help with vaccination I don't know
I don't know but whatever it is as much
pro-vaccine stuff as Fox is willing to
do I'm with it
yeah I also saw Biden talking about how
Facebook is killing people and with with
allowing all this disinformation I feel
like yeah applied Administration is
actually cracking down on stuff now once
they didn't reach their July 4th uh goal
I feel like they're actually they're
actually trying a little more now which
is great yeah so you know I I can't tell
you exactly why it happened but I'm glad
that it's a change that we're seeing
yeah uh I I also had a brief question uh
kind of totally different I'm also a
drummer do you have any tips or like any
good uh symbols or gear that you like
that that you think people that are
drummers should check out I love like
the extra special outrageously dry ride
from siljin I don't know what it's
actually called but it's one this this
one has like no shine on it whatsoever I
just think it's such a great jazz ride
that's a that's one of my favorite
pieces of equipment
yeah I have a I have a really good uh a
minor ride that's pretty dry I like a
good dry ride oh yeah David thank you my
pleasure all right Harper from South
Carolina great to hear from you really a
perfect series of questions I have to
tell you why don't we go next to Diego
from California
oh hello
what's going on I had a um question
about uh what do you think about
um the growth of people being interested
in Socialism or any sort of a radical
kind of socialist ideologies in America
um I don't know I mean I I think it's
not surprising that when a system is
failing that it creates a window of
opportunity of getting people to jump on
board with really different systems so
like for example
I would agree with the socialists that
our form of capitalism has failed so
many people
but for me the solution is
well-regulated capitalism called social
democracy in the northern European model
but I understand how if someone is just
getting introduced to some of this stuff
whatever seems the most different from
what we have will have a certain amount
of appeal so I guess I'd say it's not
it's not super surprising that that's
what's going on
yeah with the Nordic model what I found
interesting is the role of like more
radical socialist elements in those
countries that helped push for um
uh some of the Social Democratic things
like rent controls and other government
programs do you think that could be
achieved here or what's your opinion on
that generally could which part be
achieved here just having rent controls
I guess
um do you think uh
a revolutionary radical uh socialist
element in the country could serve
to bolster social democracy in America
like it did at times in Scandinavia I
think so and I've said before I had an
interview with
um a streamer who goes by the name vosh
some people say vouch some people say
um and while he is a socialist and I am
not we were in agreement that right now
the social Democrats and the Socialists
should really be pushing for very
similar socially Democratic policies
because if there is to be socialism it
will quite likely go through social
democracy now there's a different
revolutionary perspective which says no
no no no there's no need to go through
social democracy you just gotta Crush
capitalism and then put in socialism I
just even though I'm not a socialist to
me the most likely path to socialism is
through social democracy so yeah I agree
that right now social Democrats and
actual socialists could very much be
United on getting to socially Democratic
policy if and when we get the US to be
more like that at that point the social
Democrats and the Socialists can fight
it out for whether we keep going
agree at this
at this point with both parties being
parties being pretty like
pretty rough when it comes to capitalism
and they're kind of just unbridled
support for it so it does seem like
anyone left of that is kind of a it's
kind of uh left out in the dust you know
yeah no I don't uh there's a lot of
people that are just outside of that
two-party Paradigm and it's not
surprising that when something else
comes along that's appealed to them that
they would gravitate towards it no no
shock at all mm-hmm well thanks for
answering my question that was cool my
pleasure all right sir Diego very much
appreciate the call
s let's go next to where do we want to
go next I don't know
um how about
Nico from Santa Monica you're on the air
David how's it going it's going well
so I had a I had a question about
um I have a question about running
Democrats who are
socially conservative but fiscally
liberal okay
um I know a lot of times you say like if
you run a Bernie Sanders in Joe Manson
Joe manchin's West Virginia right you
just get a republican right but
do you think that
um do you think that you can run
somebody who is kind of in line with
Bernie on maybe certain
physical issues who's um
who's not necessarily in line with him
on gun rights or abortion rights or
something like that yeah I think that if
if there is a situation
in which abortion rights aren't really
at risk and you know if if Democrats
control the house and it's sort of like
there's not really you know whatever's
happening at the state level could
happen at the state level but federally
there's really no risk for example to
abortion rights I don't really have a
problem having a democrat in the senate
for example whose personal views are
that they're against abortion he or she
is against abortion and has some
conservative social positions if on
economics they're going to be a strong
vote for everything you know from
infrastructure spending to a more
Equitable tax system Etc that that's a
trade I would make in other words as
opposed to a republican if we have to
accept that there's parts of the country
where the type of democrat that can win
is one that is economically Progressive
and socially conservative I would accept
that as long as there's no no real
chance of their socially conservative
views
becoming law and that would depend on
who controls the Senate who controls the
house at the time but that's that I
don't I don't like it those aren't my
views but I think that there would be
much to gain from having a reliable vote
on the economic issues that I would say
ah whatever they're against abortion but
abortion's just not an issue right now
abortion rights aren't in question and
we'll just kind of ignore that and hope
we get some good economic policy
do you think that that could be a
blueprint uh for Democrats uh maybe not
not not to uh not to an enormous scale
because it could compromise some of our
um social values but do you think that
could be a blueprint for Democrats
taking back some uh more socially
conservative areas that they used to
that they used to win or not necessarily
win but compete in like Kentucky or
Missouri as a strategy to take
Republican seats if that's the only way
to do it I'm okay with it yeah
fair enough thanks David all right Nico
from Santa Monica thank you very much
for the call
why don't we go next to uh let's go to
Roy from South Jersey Roy you're on the
air
uh David uh sir yes um please
I was wondering
um uh for your audience if they don't
understand the Marshall Plan basically
after World War II we funded a lot of
the Western countries that we occupied
and turned them into liberal democracies
I was wondering what you think about
that as a huge International Aid package
towards uh South and Central America and
I understand that a lot of the times
that you get
um you know International funding to
countries which aren't very Democratic
it can get embezzled but um and
obviously the Republicans would never go
for it but um what would you think about
that in order to uh you know I know a
lot of people uh get mad when they hear
expand freedom and democracy they think
of the Bush model but um do you think
that could work no I think I mean okay
in a hypothetical vacuum could it work
maybe but the U.S involvement in Central
and South America has been so disastrous
over the years that first of all we have
no credibility with which we would put
in place a central in South America
um a Marshall Plan type equivalent I
think what we should be doing with
regard you know with Cuba I've already
laid out we've got to stop the Embargo
and then if we want to help help through
usaid and other organizations do it that
way I would like to see it handled
similarly when it comes to you know when
we talk about the undocumented
immigration issue one of the big factors
in people coming to the U.S is what are
the situ what are the circumstances in
their Source country so I think there
are ways to improve circumstances in the
countries people are coming from without
doing it as a Marshall Plan where we're
the idea of spreading democracy is
really code so often for the United
States for horrible interventionist
imperialism so I want to help via usaid
I want to help in that way but no I
think I I'm not I'm not loving the idea
you're proposing
all right
um one other question uh what is your
opinion on couscous
uh I am very much in favor of couscous I
particularly like that larger grain uh
larger size Israeli couscous as I know
it
um but really I am I am in favor of
couscous broadly narrowly and in most
forms quite frankly
well I'm glad we could uh agree on one
thing at least yeah absolutely
thank you okay thank you very much an
absolutely perfect phone call stand back
and stand by why don't we go next uh oh
actually no you know what I'm being told
by the 300 people on my staff that I
have to take a quick break okay so we're
gonna go to a very very quick break if
you're holding to talk to me don't hang
up and then we'll go right back to the
Discord lines momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
okay let's hear from a few more people
via Discord you can find the David
Pacman show Discord davidpackman.com
Discord very very easy to find let's go
next to Surya from New Jersey Surya I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
yeah that's correct how are you doing
today David I'm doing well
so I recently wrote an article in the uh
Washington Post or actually yeah
Washington postably was an opinion piece
about vaccines and vaccine mandates and
basically the gist of that article was
about like to stop like pleading the
anti-vaxxers and to just start mandating
vaccines sorry you you wrote it or you
read it I read it okay yeah Max boot
wrote it right yes okay good yes I know
the piece
yeah so my question to you is when do
you think we draw the line to just like
keeping kind of voluntary vaccination to
maybe saying okay well you might need a
vaccine for this place in this place or
maybe this public place so here's a
really important thing the the that's
already being done there's already 600
schools that have said if you want to be
here as an employee or as a student
you've got to be vaccinated there are
workplaces that have already done it
what Max boot was arguing about and I
talked about that article earlier in the
week he's saying government mandated
vaccination where where a state
government or any government would say
you just you have to get a vaccine and
my view on that is that there is some
precedent there's a Massachusetts case
from 1905 that says the state could man
some states could mandate vaccination I
think it's political suicide so I don't
uh I'm I'm not in favor of it partially
because I think people will still find
ways to get around it and partially
because it would be out absolute and
total political suicide so I just don't
see that but what you're talking about
which is schools businesses whatever
saying if you want to work here if you
want to go to school here you need a
vaccine that's already going on and
there seems to be no legal issue with it
at all
okay yeah thank you that was my question
very good uh yeah good good when we talk
about mandatory vaccines
it's sometimes people say use the term
required or use the term we're talking
about a government blanket mandate
versus a requirement in order to do X
and these are two very uh very very
different things okay let's continue
speaking to folks
because people want to chat that's just
the reality of what's going on right now
let's go next to Chad from Florida
hey David hey Chad are you in Florida or
Florida
well that depends on who you ask okay
fair okay good
um so my first question or you know
maybe the only one we can get to is uh
do you think the left has sort of
squandered this opportunity uh to
distance themselves from socialism
making an issue of the embargoes or the
authoritarian or sorry not socialism
communism you know making an issue of
the embargoes or the authoritarian um
aspect of the government as opposed to
saying we reject communism you know
Bernie Sanders isn't a communist he
wants to implement you know some sort of
socialized Health Care We're Not Gonna
you know he doesn't want to be Cuba
no I don't I don't think so
um let me see how can I answer this in
in sort of the most clear way
um I've seen just about every prominent
Democrat
say that they aren't supportive of 60
plus years of uninterrupted Castro
family rule in Cuba
and at the same time many of them
although not all have made it clear that
the Embargo has been completely
counterproductive and that's that's my
position I don't know that there should
be this expectation of denouncing
Communism every time you talk about Cuba
it just doesn't doesn't really make
sense to me I mean when I talk about it
I just make it clear I'm a progressive
so I don't support authoritarian
autocratic regimes run by what are
effectively dictators or at minimum
authoritarian strong men I make that
clear because my audience sometimes gets
very confused about what my positions
are on these issues but I don't think
it's it's reasonable to say every time a
Democrat talks about Cuba they should
denounce communism that sounds weird to
me
okay thanks for the answer my pleasure
my pleasure all right let's speak next
to let's just go across the pond to
Connor from Dublin Connor you're on the
air
hi hi David I have one question one
question on me this is about secret
Trump supporters so obviously um uh so
we we know lots of Irish immigrants who
live in Pennsylvania and the Irish
Community is a very liberal a very
Democratic one that they secretly voted
for Trump really and
it's it's quite strange their idea is is
that they just they moved to America
with nothing and they have and they've
worked and they have a lot of money now
and they just want to hold on to the
money they don't care about policy they
don't care about any issues they just
want to keep their money yeah so
and
so how do we how do we reach these
people
I don't I mean I I don't know that we
reached them in any particularly
different way than we reach anybody but
what you're pointing to is is very
important and we took a call from a
Chinese Canadian caller a couple of
weeks ago who pointed out a lot of the a
lot of Chinese immigrants who would be
sort of like my parents age I guess you
would say are far more conservative than
many would assume and this this gets
back to Republicans love to say that the
strategy of Democrats on immigration is
let as many people in naturalize as many
people as possible so that then they'll
vote for you in future elections I've
pointed out that that doesn't make sense
because it's a really slow process and
if the us only naturalizes 800 000
people a year and only some of them vote
and only some of them vote for Democrats
it's like a really dumb thing to do but
what's missing from it is there are way
more immigrants than people think who
actually vote for Republicans there's a
whole bunch Russian immigrants
frequently vote for Republicans
um the Venezuelan and Cuban immigrants
often vote for Republicans Chinese
immigrants of a certain age as you're
pointing out Irish so yeah it's it's not
surprising to me
great well thank you very much my
pleasure great uh great topic of an
important topic that I'm glad to see
come up frequently
let's go next
wow we have a packed waiting room it's
shocking what is going on right now I
don't even know where to go let's try
Mike from New York next Mike you're on
the air
Mike from New York you're on the air my
friend
is it our first drop Mike you've got to
unmute yourself or I won't be able to
hear you
that's too bad
that's too bad let's try mark from New
Jersey instead mark from Jersey you're
on the air
hey David how are you I'm doing very
well
awesome so I was wondering uh you know
it's today's current vaccine situation
there's a lot of misinformation that's
preventing uh people from getting
vaccines but do you think a positive
misinformation campaign could lead to a
good result something like you know
having bald guys say oh it helped me
regrow my hair and things like that
almost me status so
um no I mean so the answer is yes it
might work I mean listen the people who
buy the supplements the people who do
all the crazy you know if you're if you
would fall for that they probably would
at least some of them fall for you know
the vaccine regrew my hair uh gave me
muscle mass and works like uh you know
an erectile dysfunction pill or whatever
right I'm sure it would convince some
people but I don't think it's a great
idea what I what I would be more okay
with would be something like
calling it Trump juice and marketing it
like a soda and I as I tweeted I think
that would get some Republicans on board
I I tweeted about this earlier this week
and a lot of people latched on to it
they thought it was a good idea
Start Spreading the rumor that Democrats
are glad Republicans aren't getting
vaccinated because that means they're
going to die and then maybe Republicans
would be like screw you watch me go and
get vaccinated like that but but
straight up lies like it'll regrow hair
I I wouldn't be on board with
yeah so I know people were saying uh uh
Bill Gates is going to mind control
people but if they framed it where the
vaccine protects you from Bill Gates
mind control you know something like
that I totally know what you're saying I
totally know what you're saying it would
work for some people I would just be
listen I think it would be more benign
to just hey promoted as the Trump
vaccine if you if that's what you
believe Trump made the vaccine and Trump
took the vaccine be like Trump I think
that would basically work as well as the
regrow hair thing and it feels less
obviously dishonest although it's still
dishonest but in a less uh empirically
uh concerning way
right awesome thanks man my pleasure my
pleasure yeah there's a lot of work to
be done there that's for sure uh got to
figure out what what will work with
these people
why don't we speak next to let's go back
to New York City Evander from New York
City you're on the air
hi David hi uh all right so I have a
question so everything I've been seeing
how like Republicans treat Democrats and
the way that you know to see to try and
legislate Democrats at a government
I get the impression that the
Republicans just want to be a one-party
system they don't want to have you used
to want all Republicans and every
legislate every Senate Office throughout
the country legislative congress senate
and they just would not want any
Democrats at all in office and that's so
impression I see them getting everything
you hear him say the way this trash talk
everything they uh all progresses want
old legislation we want all the things
we stand for they just rather have
nothing to do with Democrats and only be
Republicans yeah
you're blowing up there Evander
yeah because I just you just hear them
talking I mean the way they demonize you
know like all Democrats and you just
think that they just want to be a
one-party system only Democrats and
that's how they'll see it but that's not
how America is and I just think it's
like I don't understand you think it's
like hypocrisy on their part well hold
on a second don't isn't aren't Democrats
the same and Democrats would like to
defeat Republicans in every seat as well
I know but I think that Democrats
wouldn't want to be all the old
democratic government I could see I mean
that the way this country works I mean I
guess now the way Haydn parts and
politics works I mean back then but you
would think that having a two-party
system maybe down the road you know we
had three maybe back in the day we can
look at the founding country we had
multiple parties
but now it's it's like one and the other
I mean everybody just wants their their
party to be in charge and yes yes
everybody wants it I think that's the
key Point everybody wants their party to
be in charge I think I don't know that
that's unique to Republicans
yeah but they want it to be like 100 and
I didn't say that they have not one
Democrat in the senate or a house
they'll be okay with that yeah I think
Democrats would be fine defeating every
Republican too
yeah I mean
Evander I've got to ask what's going on
in the background are you getting texts
are you playing games or you want
another call while you're on this one
what's happening there
my wife is blowing up if someone she's
just texting me she's got it okay all
right Evander I love the call I love the
question I hope to speak to you again my
friend
thank you the noise causes cancer okay
let's go next to Dylan from Connecticut
Dylan you're on the air
Dylan from Connecticut you're on the air
going for the third time Dylan from
Connecticut did you want to talk to me
all right no Dylan let's try Alex from
Baltimore Alex you're on the air
hi David can you hear me yes I can
all right hey how you doing I um I'd
like to actually have a question about
history and how other as your
well-traveled person as you are how
other cultures see their history okay
because
at least on more left-leaning people in
the United States
they read about American history and a
lot of it is shameful but and then they
personally become staying there they say
they're ashamed to be an American in
this country is nothing but evil and
racist I was just curious how do like
European people feel about such things
because they certainly have a bad
history of colonialism and atrocities to
Native people are you aware of anything
like that
um I don't I mean listen so I know
Europeans from the UK from Spain from
France from Italy which has less of a
colonial history from Belgium which has
quite a colonial history you know so on
and so forth Germany you know I what I
can tell you is all the Germans I know
feel really bad about the history of
Nazism and they sort of go out of their
way to distance and to talk about how
they completely denounce it when it
comes to places like UK France Spain
which also have and and Belgium which
have Colonial history it's just never
been a topic of conversation it's a
great question how much of their
identity in their country uh as as a you
know someone from their country is tied
up in the colonial history it's never
come up and I don't know what that tells
us but I you'd have to really ask them
that's fair I just I I'm just kind of in
the middle of those two I still consider
myself to be proud to be an American
because there's a lot of good things but
I don't sugarcoat the terrible things
we've done either
as a naturalized American I don't really
use the term proud one way or the other
I don't say I'm proud or that I'm that
there's an absence of I just think about
it more like
you know my family moved here
because the economic situation was
terrible in Argentina and it's not a
thing of Pride but I'm aware that at the
time there was an economic opportunity
here that didn't exist in Argentina and
I believe as an individual I've
benefited drastically from growing up in
the U.S rather than Argentina like I'm
uh without question I'm financially
orders of magnitude better off because
of that does that make me PR it's not
about proud it's I recognize the
opportunity that I got and I'm glad for
it you know does that make sense that's
that's totally fair I guess I could fall
in that myself that makes a lot of sense
I do have a quick silly
um food uh debate question for you
please
um I'm gonna ask you
do you prefer coffee or tea but
whichever one you pick the other one is
completely vaporized off the face of the
Earth
okay never drink it again
yeah I mean I I prefer coffee I guess if
tea were vaporized I'd have lemonade
I don't know that's fair yeah I always
said I prefer tea if it had the same
caffeine content as coffee but that's
just me okay all right very good well
I'm glad we were able to sort that out
yes thank you all right have a good day
first question was excellent excellent
excellent first question let's focus on
the positive there please my friends uh
okay thank you to everybody who called
I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't get to more
people today but we do have a time limit
and we will take calls again very very
soon
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
let's get into audience questions for
the week the first one is related to the
Cuban protests and and a situation that
we've been talking about there for about
10 days now David why do some protests
get so much more media attention than
others for example there are currently
protests happening in Guatemala and
South Africa and yet we hear nothing
about them in American Media but we hear
a lot about Cuba why is this so the the
answer there's two different answers
first there's a sort of a
commercialization of media answer and
then there's a political answer and in
the case of Cuba it's actually a little
bit of both but it's it's absolutely
true in the sense that first let's
figure out if the situations are
different in terms of their uh level of
notoriety
um in Cuba we've seen significant
protests as well as serious crackdowns
many videos getting out of uh Cuban
Police Federal local police you know
variety of different levels of law
enforcement in Cuba
um just grabbing people holding signs
off the street uh and a significant and
serious Crackdown the protests have been
related to mishandling of kovid out of
control inflation a collapsing economy
lack of resources lack of food all sorts
of different things
um similarly in South Africa there have
been at least 32 people killed in
clashes between police and protesters
the
um president of South Africa ordered
soldiers to the country's two most
densely populated provinces because
crowds were ransacking retail stores and
the protests were in response to the
jailing of the former president Jacob
Zuma
um and there's it's been significantly
chaotic in South Africa similarly in
Guatemala there have been demands for
the resignation of the president over
his mishandling of the coveted pandemic
a shortage of vaccines Etc there were
protests there in Guatemala City as well
as in other regions denouncing the
president's uh handling of the situation
um demands for the president jamate to
step down and cases are skyrocketing
hospitals are about to collapse very low
vaccination rate significant chaos in
Guatemala but yet we barely hear about
those in American Media but we hear
about Cuba so what is the explanation uh
there there's really two one
uh the history of U.S Cuban
relations is a big part of it Cuban uh
circumstances in Cuba relate to so many
American political stories including
this battle over socialism and communism
that the right has been fighting against
Communists like
Joe Biden I mean it's ridiculous right
but it's very useful for the right to
talk about Cuba and anything bad that
happens in Cuba
um there's also a much more important
from a political standpoint
cuban-american population in terms of
its impact on the results in Florida and
so politically it's a much more useful
population you know most non-guatemalans
aren't super concerned about the
guatemalan-american vote as a voting
Bloc in the United States for the mo and
this applies to Argentinian Americans
like me and right I mean there's there's
just less political utility Mexico is
certainly an interesting one because of
political reasons and Cuba is as well
similarly South African Americans not
like Cuban Americans in terms of a group
that a state can hinge on so in
particular in that context it's logical
that we're hearing more about Cuba than
we are about Guatemala and South Africa
and then there's just like the straight
up commercial narrative story which
narrative narrative is going to make
news viewers
tune in the longest and either happy or
angry at someone so that they continue
to share articles and sort of engage
because that drives ratings and AD
Revenue
because of the first piece that I
mentioned there's not as much need or
interest in appealing to Guatemalan
Americans or South African Americans
it's not going to drive ratings it's not
going to drive news Revenue talking
about Cuba very very much does and it's
a similar question actually to why do
some shootings get more attention than
others the Wright loves to say only
shootings of minorities by white people
get attention because that serves the
left the left often points out that the
right in general doesn't want to talk
about shootings unless the perpetrator
is non-white and it's like very very
clean along racial lines both stories
are the reality is there's much more to
it there's power dynamics there's what
was it an officer involved shooting or
was this
um quote civilians but there's also I
mean when you look at how many mass
shootings take place every day there's
clearly a selection bias that's taking
place and it's much similarly oriented
along the same lines two two things one
what will generate interest from the
standpoint of being a news story and
number two which shootings are of
political relevance to either or both
sides and it's a very similar thing with
which with the story of which protests
get attention there's something I'm
missing in this analysis there's more to
it
um Guatemala South Africa Cuba certainly
let me know I would love to hear it
David do you think there should be a
maximum age for president like there is
a minimum age for president so let's
ignore constitutionality because they're
simply you know there's a question as to
whether you would be able to put in a
maximum age let's imagine you could if
you wanted to and forget the
constitutionality of it so there's
there's really two questions here
there's two ways we could be thinking of
a maximum age one is we want to have
some way of limiting how long people can
be in elected office because we don't
want career politicians so as an
alternative to a term limit you could do
a maximum age that's one reason you
might want to do it the other side is
because you genuinely think we just
shouldn't have people over a certain age
doing the job even if they're not career
politicians either because you think
that after a certain age people are less
effective less cognitively able or for
whatever other reason you just don't
want older people being a president or
in some other position so if the idea is
the former which is we just want to
restrict the number of years someone can
be in elected office to event people to
prevent people like Chuck Grassley Nancy
Pelosi from staying in power for so long
there's sort of are other ways to deal
with that term limits is a far simpler
one fixing gerrymandering to eliminating
uh so many safe seats where once you
become the incumbent
no one from your party or another party
is going to knock you out I think that
would would reduce how long people stay
in power
um there are some ideas that having a
sort of Representative uh system rather
than just individual first past the post
it's either one winner or not sort of
like a percentage-based system like they
have in other countries would be a way
to do it I'm not so sure about that but
if the idea is just to kind of go the
direction of preventing career
politicians I think there are simpler
ways than a maximum age and probably
more palatable to the public ways now if
your perspective is old people in
politics are just bad remember that if
the general public overall decided that
it's a priority not to have older people
win
they could say well we're going to vote
for younger people and you don't
necessarily have to restrict Choice
there and then you get to the question
of well then why do we have a lower
limit right like if the American public
genuinely thought a 12 year old would be
better than the candidates that are
adults then they should vote for that
person but you might say most Americans
would realize that that doesn't make
sense but then you remember that they
did elect Trump after all so then that
makes you question anything that relies
on the presumed intelligence of the
electorate uh so I I think that if you
start going with an upper limit and
saying well you should have an upper
limit that raises questions of why do we
have limits at all if it's really just
about letting the American people decide
on the best candidates I think it's sort
of tough uh along those lines the bigger
question to me if the aspect of this
that's most concerning is a cognitive
issue is the possibility of saying here
we're going to put in place three or
four different requirements that
wouldn't include if you want to have
something like the Montreal cognitive
assessment you have it but maybe
something else as well I'm not against
it in principle I think that it does get
back to the issue of constitutionality
and pragmatics because it'll just never
happen I mean I would like to have a
president imagine for a second and then
this is completely anti-constitutional
it's and it in a sense it's
authoritarian because you're imposing
limits that that could be even misused
in some way against uh certain sectors
of the population but imagine if to be a
major you know to be a party nominee or
whatever Democrats and Republicans and
why would they do it or or the
Constitution put in place a rule which
said
you've got to do a Montreal cognitive
assessment you need to do a psych eval
the results of which will be published
publicly and if there's personality
disorders or whatever it's going to be
there you have to do a basic on the spot
like basic American history and
constitutionality not to the point of
like you have the knowledge of a
constitutional lawyer but just really
basic things about history uh who who
were the uh allies uh and the axis of
Evil in uh World War II or you know
there's really simple things
many candidates would immediately be
humiliated or they would actually have
to study and take it seriously and we
would end up with more informed
candidates that's super interesting to
me although I think there's an
authoritarian aspect to it and I don't
think there's any way that it happens
constitutionally so the answer to should
there be an upper age limit my question
to you is what is the goal is it to
prevent career politicians is it to
ensure that our elected officials are
cognitively capable is it because you
just don't think for whatever reason
that the country should be led by people
above a certain age depending on your
answers to those questions the approach
that could be taken varies pretty
dramatically and I'd be interested in
hearing from you about that going back
to Cuba momentarily
David what should Joe Biden do about
Cuba that's a very american-centric uh
way to ask the question and I think it's
important to start with first
Joe Biden doesn't necessarily have to do
anything about Cuba in the sense that
the United States doesn't have to be
involved in every issue in every country
that's a starting point that's not
isolationist that's we we just we don't
have to be involved everywhere all the
time now you might say hold on a second
David
the U.S is already involved in Cuba
because of the Embargo and and for other
reasons it's already entangled and I
would agree with you 100 and we'll get
into that in a second but the first
point is
reframing Joe Biden doesn't have to do
anything about what's going on in any
particular country by definition now
because part of why Cuba is the way it
is today part of
is related to the American Embargo of
Cuba
absolute minimum Joe Biden should be
getting rid of the amped up sanctions
that Donald Trump put in Barack Obama
had eased those sanctions Donald Trump
had re-instated some of those Joe Biden
should immediately step back from those
at the same time the U.S simply cannot
and by cannot I mean should not it's a
moral question should not be involved in
any kind of influence campaign for
regime change in Cuba American
involvement in regime change in central
Latin South America however you want to
slice and dice that region of the world
has been almost exclusively a disaster
and there are so many so many stories of
that you can look at Colombia
uh you can look to a lesser degree in
Argentina Nicaragua Honduras I mean
there's just so so many questions so my
preference would be because remember I'm
a progressive anti-authoritarian my
Tendencies are not fascist my Tendencies
are not authoritarian they're not
dictatorial I'm a small L Progressive
libertarian I can't support any regime
that's been in power since 1959 and that
was handed from one brother to another
doesn't matter if what it was replacing
was bad it doesn't matter if it was if
it was replacing something that was
supported by the US in the 50s I'm a
progressive libertarian so it's a there
are certain principles that are really
important and one is I don't support
dictatorial regimes police States Etc so
the U.S should not support the Castro
regime but should have zero involvement
in regime change operations uh but
beyond that I don't know that I'm hugely
inclined to say the U.S should have a
bigger and bigger role I would love to
see us Aid leveraged and used other
non-profit groups are eager to help in
Cuba make it easier for help them to do
that send food Aid send Medical Aid I
know some people say Cuba doesn't need
any medical Aid okay they do they do
um but beyond that I am very skeptical
of American involvement in Cuba because
it has been pretty disastrous for a long
time
if you I know there's it bums me out but
there are some authoritarian leftists
are they really left this I know I know
that that's a question you will ask but
there are some self-described leftists
who are authoritarian in my audience who
have a different perspective on Cuba
they really like the Castro regime
um it's tough for me to find common
ground with that because I just can't
support any kind of autocratic police
state type regime that's lasted 60 years
I just I just can't do it I can't you
know I don't support that in North Korea
I don't support it it's shorter and
different but in Venezuela and I don't
support it in Kua either send me your
thoughts what should or should not Joe
Biden be doing in Cuba we've got a great
bonus show for you today get instant
access really come on in we've got an
extra show every day by signing up at
joinpakman.com
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com David Pacman